learning more about the health of
California Senator Dianne Feinstein
calling and calls for her to resign
those calls continuing today the 89 year
old Democrat recently returned to
Capitol Hill in a wheelchair after a
nearly three-month absence due to about
of shingles now her office confirms that
she's dealing with some serious
complications Nicole Killian joins us
now from Capitol Hill with what's at
stake for Democrats and President
Biden's agenda in addition to the
Senator's Health Nicole good morning
good morning to you Tony and Senator
Feinstein's return has given Democrats a
critical vote back on big issues like
the upcoming debt limit and confirming
judges here in the narrowly divided
Senate but she is keeping a much lighter
schedule missing some votes and meetings
prompting some within her own party to
consider whether she should step aside
California Senator Dianne Feinstein came
back to the Capitol last week to a
standing ovation I want to welcome back
our College Senator Dianne Feinstein
Mrs Feinstein
Mrs Feinstein I after battling shingles
for nearly three months a spokesperson
for the 89 year old Democrat confirmed
Thursday she suffered from additional
complications including a rare
neurological disorder called Ramsay Hunt
syndrome and Encephalitis or
inflammation of the brain how is your
recovery going where earlier this week
the senator face renewed scrutiny over
her health after a Los Angeles Times
Reporter asked her about her return to
the Senate I haven't been going I've
been working you've been working from
home is what you're saying oh I've been
here I think she should step down
California congressman rocana is one of
several lawmakers demanding Feinstein's
resignation she's representing 40
million people in California we need
someone who's going to be on top of the
job Feinstein holds a seat on the
powerful Senate Judiciary Committee
where Democrats now have a one vote
advantage over Republicans so missing
one vote leaves Democrats short of
getting President Biden's judicial
nominees through through what kind of
organizations do you have to make well
we schedule things that work for her to
make sure that she's able to attend
physically I was mayor of San Francisco
for nine years as the longest serving
female senator the five-term legislator
announced in February that she would not
seek re-election next year congresswoman
Katie Porter is running for her seat any
concerns about her ability to serve out
her full term I think it's very very
clear that it's time for a change in
California that's why I declared to run
now there are several others running for
Feinstein's seat including California
congressman Adam Schiff who is backed by
former house Speaker Nancy Pelosi if
Feinstein were to retire Governor Gavin
Newsom has pledged to appoint a black
woman but that is why some are
questioning the relationship between
Feinstein and Pelosi's eldest daughter
who is now assisting her here in
Washington the former speaker has
defended Feinstein's decision to stay
and serve out her term although a source
close to the speaker tells CBS news that
there is no political agenda here back
to you
Nicole thank you
this is very layered yeah it's very
layered I mean she's had a historic
career Sports represent 40 million
people in the state of California I
don't think her younger self would have
chosen her to be in this particular role
at this particular time but she is
expressing that's where she wants to be
the question is how much of her is left
in there making that decision to do the
job yeah and to do the job yeah and the
bottom line is you want somebody who is
healthy and up for the job and when you
physically look at it that does not
appear to be the case based on what
we're looking at yeah so you just want
her to be healthy yeah